hi
now the question came up how do I study
with link so we're gonna do an
experiment here we're gonna show you how
I work with three different devices all
right first of all I just happen to have
this book handy I saw it foreign
language education the easy way by
stephen krashen I am very indebted to
Professor crashing for his insistence on
the importance of input when I study a
language my main objective is to get the
language in me through input activities
listening and reading and once I have a
certain level in the language where I
understand I have good comprehension I
have a vocabulary then I want to start
speaking and I want to start speaking a
lot but initially when I don't
understand when I can't speak well I'm
far more motivated to work on my
comprehension comprehension activities
so I'm gonna set it up with three or
four languages where I'm at different
levels just to give you an idea of how I
work so let's start with German because
I have started doing German this week
even though I haven't spoken German for
the longest time and the reason is
because I have a Skype interview in
German on Friday so in order to refresh
myself in that language I'm doing a lot
doing a lot of listening and reading
which I can do on my iPhone and here I
don't know if this is visible here but
you'll see that I have a thing called
Deutsche gosh if day written by a person
called my which is an audiobook that I
found on audible.com and I went to an
ebook site the name of which escapes me
and I downloaded the e-book so I listen
to the audio on my iPhone and I can open
up this the text here there's 18
chapters and so I let's say if I'm in
chapter 13 and it takes a little while
to come up but actually to be honest I
prefer Syria you see here and the blue
words of the war
are new to me but I'm not going to
demonstrate the actual linking activity
on this small device because I want to
get to that on the computer but just to
show you that I spend a lot of time
doing this right here on my iPhone so I
can listen I can read I can look up
words you know and I have the audio you
know text-to-speech on my computer I
pick up you know a translation in
dictionary here and I do the same here
on my iPad and in fact and you'll see
the different things that I've saved
here
deutschland func here I have this gift
mi so I have the same text on my iPad
and they sync and I I just find this a
lovely way to study because I can sit
there comfortably I don't have to be at
my computer I got essentially the same
functions as on the computer and I can
go from page to page going through this
thing you know saving the words that I
want to save the way we do it link so
that's just to let you know that these
are the kinds of tools that you can use
for your input input activities if this
were a lesson from our library then I
would have the sound to listen to right
here however since I purchased the
audiobook separately from the e-book in
fact there's no audio here there's just
the text there is of course
text-to-speech but there isn't the audio
of the whole thing and so I listen on my
iPhone when I am in the car when I'm
washing the dishes so I'm getting it
from both sides both the audio and the
text and that really helps me to improve
my comprehension and increase my
vocabulary and now I will demonstrate
the same on our website so here again
now the shows up a little differently on
the website simply because we're in this
sort of transition from the classic what
we call a classic view
to the to the bait of you so let me open
the lesson here and here we have a
screen capture in fact it is working in
it alright so here we have this Deutsche
GiftA it said from Manfred my and now I
happen to be already up to here in this
thing so I take my because it didn't in
fact sink immediately or there's a bit
of a time delay and we're working on
improving that but what I do is I use
the arrow keys so hymn of praise low
buzz him then I don't really need that
word I can figure out what that means so
I hit k k means that I don't need that
word I already know it hasta Rawdon
hasta Haddon that's also a hate tirade
yeah I don't need that word I have I hit
a cake so I am Li reading along here
reading along outside M Gabba speedo
fest environment mus an alpha motion
mass rallies now off mention that to me
a new word rallies assuming that's
correct so I I hit the right arrow key
and that saves that word so that word is
now in my database and that means I can
review it in flashcards or however and
now here is a phrase you know Devon
vehicle man's ik newest way and seen
contact so I clicked the first word Dan
and I hit shift and I hit the last word
and so I actually now have saved that
whole long phrase and then I hit if I
hit the right arrow key
they saves it and I hear it again and if
there are individual words within that
that I want I can click on them like and
see in avoid all right
sometimes the translation from Google
Translate is not good if I don't know
that it's not good I'm stuck with it if
on the other hand I realize that it's
not as good as it could be I sometimes
will go in and edit it so let's
look again yeah whose effect could
hardly escape that's not a very good
translation whose effect we would have
difficulty avoiding man it's good enough
I take it because the translation in my
mind doesn't have to be a hundred
percent it's basically a hint as we say
and as I see this phrase not again an
individual word or a short phrase I'm
like to see likely to see it again a
long phrase like this I won't see again
because a sentence is typically unique
but I liked it and it'll come up in the
dictation and so I'll hear this and I
may have to then try and type it out
anyway I continue along
Knutson now notes ttan it's a word that
I already know I no longer want that
highlighted in yellow so I hit K and
then I move along and that's not such
out dealers you don't understand it that
positive dot Seuss tellin to represent I
already know what that is there was a
point in my learning where I didn't know
that word and I saved it but the way I
normally move my words to known is when
I come across them and I suddenly
realized this word is not part of my
vocabulary so thus Jesus verse - bought
a bike knit agnus sport event sport I
guess yeah I think I'll keep that word
for now if I see the second or third
time and I I'm comfortable that I know
it I can always convert it to know so
assume Eastmoreland a.m. lunch stop fund
took place yeah the Deutsche in sport
LaVon a four-time us year to four as
never before
so here's a nice little phrase that
somebody else has saved and actually I
like that I'd see X before as never
before
I'll take that phrase and then ever
before
yeah that now is a phrase that is in my
database and that's likely to show up
again so then I hit my arrow key and
that takes me over to the next page and
once medallion I know
very judgmental smiling bigger shift
india shift that's worth keeping because
one of the difficulties in german is the
daddy does how these different articles
and pronouns change so i'm going to keep
that all right nation's ranking yeah
that's good
I will take that but also in their nazi
own invasion there's another phrase
that's gonna help me that's gonna help
me with these daddy dusts type situation
in German and I also get a different
translation from google translate Nazi
own Nazi own and Viet Cong now is in
nations valuation still good enough as a
hint for this for this phrase so
basically that's all I do
I go through it and and I save the words
now if I want to review these then I
will go to what is known as the
vocabulary section and there I will see
basically I have to make sure that I
show these where are it not a to Zed but
by creation date a desert of course is
alphabetical my greatest interest in
these if I'm going to be flash guarding
or doing dictation or multiple choice is
to see them the ones that I've most
recently come across so I could do them
in flash cards by clicking here and
typically when I do flash cards I make
sure that everything is on the front so
here I've adjusted the setting in the
flash cards to make sure everything is
on the front of the card and I do that
because I just want to be exposed to the
cards I don't personally believe that
scratching my head to try and remember
the meaning is going to do me that good
that much good I just prefer to flip
through them very quickly
I sometimes when I'm doing the flash
cards
that's when I change the status I may
even change it to known here in their
Nazi onand via toon okay which I
recently saved and I'm I might make a
tattoo I else yeah two for I see this
again I can also true for okay so all of
this is helping to drive these phrases
into my brain I very often will click on
what's lost it for a sec here I will
click on show phrases only because I
actually prefer doing flashcards just
with phrases because I think it does
more for me it's helping me to kind of
get familiar with the structure of the
language whereas mostly the words I am
going to learn them if I see them often
enough in meaningful meaningful content
context so let's just move along here
very quickly in the case of Korean it's
going to be mostly the same except I am
not as far along so I will save more
words and phrases and the text-to-speech
helps me a lot I don't think I'll go
into detail on that because it would be
very similar to what I do in German if I
go to my Polish again it's going to be
similar it's just that I'm not as far
along as in German what I wanted to show
you quickly was some of the resources
that I use audible.com if you're
learning one of the languages that they
offer which is essentially Spanish
German French Italian maybe it's a
tremendous resource and you download it
to your computer and you can also take
it right into your you know iPhone
Publio dot PL in Poland is an example of
an ebook audiobook site that I found
similarly here this Deutschland hint
igloo is a German podcast that I found I
found them by googling alright and what
I do once I find good resources I have a
thing here on my computer called
language resources and I got them for
polish Ukrainian Czech Korean Portuguese
Spanish Chinese German etc etc and
make sure that I put any good websites
with resources there so that when I I
never know when I'm gonna go back to a
language then I can find resources so I
think that's perhaps good enough for now
just to get started on it please let me
know if you have any questions if you
want me to focus more on some aspects of
what I do I would be very happy to do so
thank you for listening bye for now
you